so this film is based on the works of
William Shakespeare I don't know how
many like 15 16 year-olds are really
into the King Henry plays but do you
hope that this is something that gets
people inspired to delve into that more
absolutely I mean it's not it's not
really it's not Shakespeare but it's
also not exact and of it draws from
history and it draws from Shakespeare
but it really has been put fully through
David and Joel's own lens which I think
is what's so great about the movie is
they really you know put it through
their at their eyes and their vision I
think you can really feel that in the
movie that it's not exactly one or the
other and it really is their own thing
but I mean I've always loved history and
so yeah I hope that it inspires people
to delve more into the history and
everything because it's it is so
interesting was all my favorite parts of
working on the movie was the research
process I'm just really kind of delving
into all of it right that's cool how do
you pick the roles that you want to do
and it is this type of movie like
something that was on your wish list I
mean I loved period pieces I'm always
open to hearing about it a great period
piece but as soon as I as soon as I read
even just the the you know the important
scene between Katherine Henry which is
with it what I auditioned with I was so
impressed with just her her strength and
the really kind of comb level-headedness
that she harnesses that strength with
and I think you know it's really rare to
see a woman of that time period speaking
in the way that she does and and having
the voice that that she's given in the
story and so I really loved that about
her there's real parallel in the story
between how going through what he's
going through in order to be crowned the
king and sort of like what young actors
in Hollywood go through now do you do
you see that in the film as well
absolutely I mean I think there's tons
of parallels that can be drawn from this
story and related back to what's going
on today whether it be talking about you
know the business or even just like you
know pull it like political power
structures in which people are thrust
into power and they don't really know
what to do that I think that that can
you know we can find parallels you know
with a lot of things for sure yeah it
wasn't like working those scenes with
Timothy is there but he has like a real
intensity on screen is the same thing
true on a soundstage
absolutely I mean I think it's always
incredible to work with somebody who has
invested
much of themselves into a role and is
and it's really giving their their all
to it and I think that you know it can
be intimidating to work with people
whose talent and whose work you you
admire so much but I think that it can
only make you better and it only you
know contributes to the the energy and
the urgency that there was for me to
kind of do the best that I possibly
could but it was incredible I mean
everybody was just really amazing to
work with he is not for really bringing
the drip on a red carpet for like really
doing it out and that premiere like as
we said this tonight so is there gonna
be like a royal theme are you guys gonna
go for it a hundred percent like what's
it gonna be like well you'll have to
wait and see for tonight I think
everybody's gonna pull up with their
with their with their respective looks
and ya know I'm excited to see what
everybody's wearing and to wear my my
likely